descendants three is coming back this
summer and we can't wait to see mal in
the gang again today we're taking a look
at Mel's backstory stay tuned to find
out how one of her enemies became her
BFF she might want you to believe she's
rotten to the core but mal is everyone's
favorite VK turned hero
the purple haired daughter of Maleficent
basically ruled the Isle of the Lost she
was mean and tough and no one dared to
cross her she had a hard time adjusting
when she was selected to move to auradon
she pretended that she was good while
she schemed with her BFFs but mal is
anything but evil she's kind and fights
for fairness she's stylish and cool
she's also a great friend and girlfriend
but there's a lot more to Mao than just
what you see in The Descendants movies
thanks to the novels and other sources
of canon we know a lot about Mouse
backstory we're going to take a look at
all of these details so you can know
everything there is to know about mal
we're so excited to learn even more
about her in the third movie mommy
issues we can't talk about mouths
backstory without talking about her
mommy and shoes
seriously Maleficent is basically Mommy
Dearest she's just not a good mom here's
what we know about Maleficent she had a
baby with some unknown character that
she describes as a weak human more on
that later Maleficent is the worst of
the worst villains she's a powerful
magic fairy with the ability to turn
into a dragon everyone is scared of her
even the other villains Maleficent was
the most powerful villain who was banned
by King Adam to the Isle of the Lost
most of her power comes from a magical
scepter she also had a magical spell
book in The Descendants books Maleficent
has a magical bird Maleficent always
puts herself above everyone else
including her daughter she also has her
daughter do all her dirty work in the
prequel novel Isle of the Lost
she makes mal go after her magical
scepter even though whoever touches it
will end up cursed in the first movie
she forces mal to steal the fairy
godmothers wand which is kept in a
museum so that mal can bring magic back
to the island then she sends a monster
after mal and her friends because she
doesn't trust her she tries to teach mal
to be as evil as possible when we
first meet mal she wants nothing more
than just to be like her mom she wants
her mom's approval she tries her best to
be as evil as possible in Isle of the
loss we learned that mal was not invited
to a birthday party at age six will tell
you all about whose birthday it was in a
few minutes
well Maleficent was super offended on
behalf of mal she causes a ton of drama
with the other villain parents what is
it with Maleficent getting so offended
by party invitations
seriously it was not getting invited to
princess Aurora's christening that led
to all the drama in Sleeping Beauty
nothing mal ever does it's good enough
for Maleficent she's not an affectionate
mother and Maui isn't quite sure whether
her mom even loves her eventually mal
learned that it's okay to step away from
a toxic parent even though Maleficent is
her mother she's a terrible influence
mal learns about love and acceptance
from her friends and they become her
chosen family
Maleficent ends up cursed as a lizard
that mount keeps in her dorm maybe
she'll learn some valuable parenting
lessons while she's trapped as a reptile
we sure hope so Mouse BFFs when we first
meet mal in descendants she's the
ringleader of a tough group of BK's her
best friends are Evie Jay and Carlos
they're the fiercest gang on the Isle of
the Lost
they're also the first BK's chosen to
attend auradon prep you for have been
chosen to go to a different school in
auradon
all of them are excited to get off the
Isle but they have a hard time getting
rid of their evil ways eventually they
all find their home and they find family
in each other but have you ever wondered
how they ended up as friends Evie is the
brilliant and stylish daughter of the
Evil Queen from Snow White everyone
thinks she's ditzy because she's so into
fashion but it turns out that she's
actually really smart we love that Evie
proves you can be both girly and
intelligent according to the books Evie
and mal were originally enemies when
Evie was six years old she and her mom
did not invite mal to her birthday party
Maleficent was cruel and so is mal who
can blame her for not inviting a party
pooper Maleficent goes crazy on the Evil
Queen and mal is super impressed by how
fierce her mom is mal holds a grudge
against TV for years as teenagers she
tries to trap Evie at a party in revenge
when Maleficent makes mal go after her
scepter she recruits Evie she was going
to make Evie touch the scepter which
would make her fall asleep for a
in years while they're on this journey
mal realizes evey is actually an amazing
friend
she doesn't curse her and they become
besties evey always accepts Mel without
judgment by the time they go to auradon
prep they're like sisters
Mel's two other best friends are Jay and
Carlos Jay is the son of Jafar he's a
thief he was really mouths first friend
on the Isle and they make a game of
stealing he has to steal stuff for his
dad to sell at his shop oh how the
mighty have fallen
Jafar used to be so powerful Jay ends up
becoming a star athlete at auradon prep
Carlos is the son of Cruella De Vil
Cruella forces her son to sleep in her
dressing room because she loves her furs
more than him she also convinces him
that all dogs are evil malar rigidly
fakes a friendship with carlos so that
he'll throw a party while his mother is
away mal wants to trap Evie with bear
traps as a revenge but Carlos feels bad
about it and saves Evie he goes with
them to get the scepter because he's
invented a device that seeks out magic
it was communicating with the scepter at
auradon prep carlos gets a lot more
confident he also ends up becoming the
world's biggest dog lover mouths love
life if you saw descendants - you
probably saw some serious chemistry
between mal and Harry hook in the first
novel Harry is not a character at all
but he's introduced later as the middle
child in the movies there's definitely
some hinting that mal and Harry have a
past together and if you ask the actors
they'll tell you it's true dub Cameron
and Tomas Doherty came up with a
backstory for their characters they said
that they dated which is why they have
such chemistry but according to the
novel's this never actually happened and
it's never directly mentioned in the
movies so it is not canon but Dov and
Tomas probably came up with this because
they were crushing on each other they're
dating in real life you know but
according to the jr. novelization of the
second movie here is another love
interest he kisses Gil in the books mal
says she doesn't know what love feels
like and she says that no one really
dates on the island but when she comes
to Oregon she catches the eye of one
handsome prince Ben who later becomes
king is totally enamored by the rebel he
sees good in her from the beginning it's
because of Ben that the V K's get a
chance to come to Oregon in the first
place
Mao tries to trick
with a love potion as part of her scheme
but on their first date he falls into
the lake mal thinks he's drowning and
tries to save him even though she cannot
swim he realizes that she's a really
good person and he falls for her even
though the love potion is worn off he
lets her think that he's still under the
spell in the second movie he finds out
that she's been using magic she runs
back to the Isle of the Lost but he goes
after her with the health of ebj and
Carlos mal has to save him from uma
later uma shows up at the cotillion she
has been under a love spell mal kisses
Ben using true love's kiss
to break the spell she reveals that she
has been in love with him for a long
time these two are seriously couple
goals they always see the best in each
other and they encourage each other to
be better
plus they have overcome a lot we can't
wait to see more of their relationship
in the next movie Mao's enemies as a VK
now has several enemies of course mouths
biggest enemy is actually herself she's
constantly fighting against her
upbringing as a villain because deep
down she's actually a good person then
mal has to deal with her mom in the
first movie one of mouths main enemies
is Audrey when mal and the other vks
first arrive at auradon prep audrey is
dating Ben Audrey is a classic mean girl
she tries really hard to sabotage mouths
life in auradon audrey is not in the
second movie but we know she'll be back
in the third movie and she looks like a
villain in the second movie mal faces an
old enemy uma is the daughter of Ursula
she's a pirate now that mal has left the
island
uma is basically the VK in charge
everyone is scared of her she has hairy
hook and gill to do her bidding
but uma and mal weren't always enemies
they used to be friends they used to
team up to play pranks on people when
they were kids
according to Isle of the Lost they tried
to prank Cruella De Vil but mal falls
off the dogs puma tries to save her but
it was a joke all along mal dumps a
bucket of shrimp on Emma's head she
meant it to be funny but uma didn't
think so no matter how much Emma washed
her hair she could never get the fishy
smell out then mal got everyone to call
uma shrimpie they became sworn enemies
after that in the second movie uma feels
left behind
Bimal and the other V Ches she's super
jealous she kidnapped spend so that mal
will give her fairy godmothers wand but
mal gives her a fake then umma shows up
at cotillion
she puts Ben under the love spell and
once the spell breaks Malan umma have an
epic showdown umma turns into an octopus
like sea witch just like her mom mal
also transforms into a creature uma
swims away but we know we haven't heard
the last of her Mouse powers that leads
us to one of the most important things
about mal her powers when she has her
fight with uma mal gets so angry that
she turns into a dragon she gets this
power from her mom but instead of using
it for evil she uses it to protect her
loved ones also like her mom Mouse eyes
glow green when she gets angry it's a
good reminder that mal isn't fully human
she might not be human at all actually
dub Cameron has described her as a pixie
technically Maleficent is an evil fairy
mal inherits her mom's magical abilities
she is able to cast spells with the help
of the SPO book she's also very
successful at making potions mal also
has some powers that aren't magical for
one she's really talented artists in the
first movie we see her spray-painting
graffiti she draws a lot throughout the
film mal is also really good with a
sword she had to learn that growing up
on the Isle of the Lost
now has some pretty cool abilities but
it's definitely her awesome heart that
makes her such a great character who is
Maus dad there's been a lot of
speculation about mouthes dad who is he
we know that we're going to see him in
descendants three he was originally
described as a weak human by Maleficent
but it turns out that Maus dad is most
likely Hades the god of the underworld
from Hercules but Hades is not human
I know I got it I got the concept we
have so many questions
did Maleficent lie about who Mouse
father is so she wouldn't ask too many
questions
that seems like something Maleficent
would do or did Hades trick Maleficent
into believing he was human
villains are pretty sneaky you know we
cannot wait to find out more about
mouths father descendants three comes
out later this year most likely in July
like the first two films what's your
favorite thing about mal let us know in
the comments below
and that's it for Maus back story be
sure to subscribe to the things to keep
up with descendant 3 news see you next
time
[Music]